music rights uh
it's a very complicated world and
there's two sides of things there's the
master recording which is the actual
recording of something and then there's
the composition underneath it did
someone write a melody or a vocal line
and when you sample directly from
another track you're really violating
both of those in most cases like the
actual recording and if it's long enough
the composition of what's happened and
it became such a part of culture because
people were doing it it inspired so much
creativity but you'd get releases where
all of a sudden the original rights
holder is wait a second that's my song
and you watch you know these claims get
made and royalties being taken and you
can clear things you can go to the
rights holders and say i want to use
this in my track and they can sign off
on it and you will give them a split of
the song or a buyout fee something along
those but it's com that takes forever
tracking down the rights holders finding
that process just stifles creativity and
so what we wanted to do is create a very
clean abstraction
where you don't have to worry about it
you go in you find the sound you get
inspired and you start writing and and
you don't have to worry about the
clearance it's there we protect you and
we really do want to make it so that
when you're in that creative flow that
you don't have to have those thoughts
going through your head about whether or
not this is gonna be legal
so if i were to
sing the word gelato right now and go
and then somebody makes that into a song
i could then sue them and make them
either take it out of the song and get
damages for it and so if i wanted to
take other people's stuff what you're
saying is how do i sit there and jam and
make a creative song if
i have to go every time i want to add
some beat ask somebody for clearance how
and if i take royalty free i have to pay
nothing forever for the life of it you
have bought that sample from somebody or
made it yourselves you buy that from
somebody they sign an agreement that
says i no longer own this splice owns it
and anybody who splice sells it to down
the road gets it for free forever when i
sign up for my ten dollars a month i
know that everything on the platform i
never pay for again and if i were to
take
if i sold that gelato beautiful melody i
just sang
to splice
and somebody made a song that became
baby shark or whatever and made a
billion dollars off of it or 100 million
dollars off it i would see point zero
dollars am i correct uh you wouldn't see
zero point zero so
close there's nuance to like what you're
allowed to do with things you can't
redistribute the sample on its own as
like another piece of a sample line and
technically they own it but it's they
are licensing it to us in this way they
get paid for a lot of our deals the
majority of our deals in splice get a
pro rata share of the downloads so you
get something every time someone
downloads it you just don't get
something in the
track so on the recording side and look
i think that's our artists know that
going in that's not a surprise that's
not a secret but they're able to get
relatively large payouts from the
hundreds of thousands of people
downloading their sounds and that's a
great income stream for them they don't
have to worry about maybe someone will
have a hit they just get paid on the
download and it's been really great to
take and build careers off this like
interesting abstraction in the space in
this royalty-free music
so just to make up a story here i'm a
young mark knopfler i play guitar
particularly well i haven't written
sultans of swing yet and i'm just doing
little guitar riffs or even playing
chords i put my collection a finger
picked yeah stratocaster amazing
harmonic
music and i put those that mark
knopfler-esque
sample up there
people start downloading it it becomes
popular in one song other people start
saying hey where'd you get that from i
found it on splice
now
everybody starts downloading it you've
got hundreds of thousands of members
paying tens of dollars a month which is
hundreds of dollars a year you're making
tens of millions of dollars you take the
million samples or 100 million samples
that get downloaded this month and
everybody gets a penny per download 10
cents per dollar whatever it happens to
be it's a lot more than streaming
royalties i'll tell you that and it
doesn't have the same scale but it
what's cool is it proportionally grows
with how much we bring in and what's
good too is a lot of this stuff is
evergreen so it sticks around and people
come in it doesn't necessarily need to
be a hit so like new people join the
platform they come back and they find
that amazing guitar sample and you can
release more content all the time
because these are very they're smaller
snippets right some of these artists can
create this
like just in a day in their flow it's a
unique i think it's like people are
finding a really nice balance of
sound design and sample creation as a
new incremental form of their artistry
and career so like you can be working on
full-length tracks and then do these
smaller tracks as well so if and what
are the top 10 of people who are putting
up samples there are they putting up
dozens of samples hundreds of samples
thousands of samples your top 20 of uh
creators how many samples do they have
up there packs are somewhere between 100
and 500 sounds and those can range the
difference between 100 and 500 is like
how long they are because some of them
are just one shot like drum hits and
stuff right so you want a lot of those
and then with the loops that have more
melodic or longer form content you can
do less of those and they get very
popular
so what would somebody in the top 25
percent of creators be able to
make per month slash year off of their
modest collection of sounds it's really
the dollar amount is very interesting
because this is a unique revenue stream
for them one it's usually all
incremental two it's not really stepped
on the way musicians are used to with oh
there's a label in between and then
there's a this in between processing and
then or i'm touring and i have all those
crew and all the travel expenses some
people make a couple thousand dollars a
month off their tracks some people have
made hundreds of thousands of dollars
off their works and what i love is just
how happy they are for this revenue they
can be a studio musician and make their
rent or mortgage every month
for sure
and when you're a studio musician
and you play on a track you just do a
work for hire maybe you get some
residuals but probably you don't and
yeah session musicians deals in session
musician land are all over the place and
to have i do some of my favorite text
messages of when a musician friend just
says man i just got my splice check and
i'm just like so thankful for it amazing
what is the split between creators and
splice it really depends so all the
deals are pretty custom sometimes
there's a buy out sometimes we really
encourage everybody to continue to have
a royalty just because we want them to
see growth if they do very well on the
platform and you said that you take a
certain percentage of revenue and split
it between everybody is it 50 50 70 30.
yeah it depends every deal is different
there's no you would on a deal by deal
basis yeah yeah because it's like how
much content is coming in what's unique
about the artists sometimes they draw
more people to the platform
some we have a big in-house team as well
so i think we're constantly i think one
of the things if you ever look at us in
the news
i very rarely like to talk about any
kind of splice metrics or numbers other
than artists paid i just like to talk
about artists paid like we announced 40
million paid out to artists so if in the
last year you're doing 10 million a year
or something to artists
yeah more than that it's amazing yeah
yeah it's really cool so you know that
that is the stat i'm proud of and i
think that as we continue to scale
listen to your nft episode and i heard
you talking about how cool it would be
if with music rights it wasn't just a
consumption thing but it was more of a
how to use this and it looked like the
music industry i think what was really
cool where we are is we have created
this royalty-free opportunity which is
what's used in half a top 40 music at
any given time wow yeah and then now
continuing to understand the artists and
their needs
where does scarcity where does
uniqueness where does maybe royalty
bearing all these different
opportunities to build off of where we
are and keep paying out artists i think
it's a nice long road ahead of us on on
how we can continue to evolve the
content side of the business can anybody
start putting samples and on there
i wish that the goal we talked about
wanting to build an open ecosystem but
originality is so important on the
platform and look i can't have people
running into copyright issues because
they pulled something and quality issues
one of the things i think that's we're
most known for is these samples can be
pretty much dropped right into your
track
and that's a rare sight so i i think as
technology evolves and as our community
and and we want to lower the bar so more
people can participate but right now we
really think that quality and
originality are higher concerns than the
openness right now
let me just say up front go to
linkedin.com unicorn and post your job
for free that's it i'm giving the call
to action upfront
linkedin.com unicorn get your first job
for free and here's why you should do
that it's because many small business
owners are super busy today we all know
that you're searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates for a
job opening would be better spent
growing your business we all know this
and you get so many people applying who
are not qualified it's hard linkedin
jobs makes it easier to get the right
candidates who are worth your time
interviewing and it's fast and it's free
you can create a free job posting in
minutes on linkedin jobs and you'll
reach the world's largest professional
network of over 750 million people you
know this because you're on linkedin
every week you're probably using it
multiple times a day if you're like me
and you can focus on candidates with the
skills and experience you need and use
screening questions to get your role in
front of only the most qualified people
and those screening questions are great
for filtering out people who are serious
or not then you use simple tools on
linkedin jobs to quickly filter and
prioritize who you would like to
interview and eventually hire we love
linkedin jobs here at launch and in 2021
we've hired a third producer curriculum
designer and a couple of researchers who
are crushing it once again linkedin jobs
will help you find the right candidate
worth interviewing faster every week
nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin so post your job for free at
linkedin.com unicorn to post your first
job for free terms and conditions apply
because they're giving you a free job
listing